wie schlimm ist die schlägerei die ich
bis jetzt hat das wonnemar schlägerei
mädchen
ich habe meine freundin wollten dieses
mädchen aufstechen herzlich kommt zu
einem video leute die wir uns heute mal
wieder mit deutschlands zukünftigen
leistungsträger beschäftigen ich weiß
ich als investor sollte mich dann nicht
zu weit aus dem fenster lehnen leute
aber wir haben heute wieder einiges am
start und zwar eine neue folge die
strengsten eltern der welt und zwar habe
ich noch instrument ist gesorgt um
einsendung der besten die strengsten
eltern der welt folgen gebeten und wir
haben eine sehr sehr knackige episode
gefunden ist werde ich mein volk leute
macht das auf jeden fall das reduziere
wahrscheinlichkeit euch den kleinen zeh
schmerzhaft zu stoßen um 60 prozent
soweit einfach nur die zahlen also ich
denk mir das ja nicht aus reden wir gar
nicht lange drum leute das wie ich höre
ist so sollte anschauen werden das leben
nicht jeden tag und ich zurück
alles klar buchholz bei hamburg
die 16 jährige aylin rainer mit ihrer
alleinerziehenden mutter andrea okay
heute das ist allen die beschreibung
verrät uns dass eileen bereits 20
anzeigen wegen körperverletzung kassiert
hat die alten wie alt ist und noch mal
buchholz bei hamburg
hier lebt die 16 jährige aylin rainer 16
16 und hatten 16 16 16 hat schon 20
hatten wegen körperverletzung kassiert
das ist ein strammes pensum muss man
sagen also ihre mutter sieht recht
normal aus aber was ist was ist ihr
vater ist der profi boxer
ich hatte ungefährlich okay es ist
dieses level wenn ihr so viele anzeigen
gehabt dass eure mutter euch verbietet
aus dem haus zu gehen also erste frage
wenn sie 20 anzeigen hat wie sie ist
noch nicht im jugendknast also ich weiß
also heute das ja so eine anzeige kommt
wird verarbeitet anzeige geht raus und
zeigen was auch erstmal verarbeitet
werden da muss irgend ein urteil
gesprochen werden pipapo aber es ist
schon ein geiles level 16 jahre alt
schule abgebrochen sind wir auch hier
und so viele anzeigen was ihre mutter
verbiegt vor die tür zu gehen
die 16 jährige aylin ungefähr bis zu 15
sie sagt das als wären sie nicht selbst
dabei gewesen
nach aktuellen daten und erhebung des
eileen renner instituts eingetragener
verein könnte ich bis zu 15 schlägereien
gehabt haben ist das für die polizei ist
doch scheißegal ob stadtpolizei land
polizei wurden bis polizei hauptsache
ich komme mit einer anzeige nach hause
mama darum geht es doch am ende war was
meint ihr wie sieht das leben von berlin
so ausgeht die straßen stehen
da sehe ich jetzt nichts verwerfliches
dran ich glaube im alter von 16 jahren
und gerade wenn man mit 16 jahren die
beschreibung sagt 20 anzeigen alliance
selbst sagt bis zu 15 anzeigen hat dann
hat man auf jeden fall die geistige
reife seine eigenen regeln aufzustellen
köln chorweiler hier lebt der 17 jährige
markus lahms er hat jeglichen respekt
vor seinen eltern christiana und werner
verloren war wird eine weltweite ein
moment achtet achtet auf die bierflasche
im moment essen ersten feinschmecker
muss man sagen gute guter geschmack
markus er hat jeglichen respekt vor
seinen eltern christiana und werner
verloren mit sechs jahren haben sie ihm
bereits für neun jahre in ein heim
gesteckt markus war verhaltensauffällig
ja ok
ja also ich weiß wie soll ich das jetzt
sagen liebe eltern von markus aber
vielleicht ist ein kinderheim nicht
immer der optimale ort für die
entwicklung von dem kind versteht was
ich meine ja okay wenn ein kind
verhaltensauffällig ist dann ja
natürlich ist es nicht so geil aber
einfach für neun jahre in heimen gegeben
wow da kommt er zurück und fällt sich
komisch ich kann mir das nicht erklären
er war doch nur neun jahre in meinem job
ich muss muss sagen das ist wirklich
einfach geisteskrank turbulent für eine
kindheit leute das ist zu extrem mit
sechs jahren haben wir ihnen deshalb mit
sechs jahren alt also ich will es auch
gar nicht runterspielen so locker gibt
es viele terror kinder in deutschland
die echt krass sind so die ihren eltern
richtig schon mal machen aber wenn du
dein kind mit sechs jahren für neun
jahre ins heim gibst was erwartest du
dann das ist zurück kommt mit abitur und
abgeschlossenem studium oder da muss ich
allerdings sagen leute kennen sich auch
freunde von mir vielleicht bekannter von
mir die auch so mit ihren eltern umgehen
ja also ich nenne jetzt keine namen aber
es gibt auch welche er eine person die
schon auch der eigenen mutter gegenüber
mal so ansage macht so machen wir hier
ich habe keinen bock mehr
erst mal wieder ins heim geben das ist
eigentlich eigentlich die geschichte
auch traurig leute wie immer bei die
strengsten eltern der welt ist die
geschichte auch traurig und ich will
mich eigentlich auch nichts zu nur rein
drüber lustig mache ich aber sinnvoll
situation erzählen heute was denkt sie
sich nur wenn ja dann wieder für neun
jahre ins heim vielleicht ist danach
dann besser nochmal für ein 80 jahres
heim dass ich bin schon eher der typ der
das machtwort hat und selten das was an
was mir gesagt wird im vergleich würde
ich aber auch kraß markus so ist ist 17
ist einer der ganz wenigen leute die
tatsächlich mehr oder weniger legal
substanzen konsumieren weil die schränke
eltern der welt ist er da gefühlt
siebenjährige die rauche und sich sogar
einmal an die berner so trinkt ihr so
erst okay und ich meine seine story ist
auch kraß er war neun jahre im heim das
ist krass ist geisteskrank dagegen eine
scheinbar die ganze zeit zu hause waren
sich anzeigen
christiana und werner wissen nicht
weiter
sie haben alles für ihren sohn gegeben
versucht ihm zu helfen
doch genützt hat es scheinbar gar nicht
mehr leute das ist eigentlich dass es
auch es ist nie ist es nicht nur ein
lass dich leute es auch teilweise
wirklich krass traurig und ein gedanke
der mir sofort durch den kopf wenn ich
das höre ist einerseits zu sagen alles
gegeben andererseits hat kind für neun
jahre ins heim abgegeben ist auf ich
will gar nicht so krass aber auf den
ersten blick ist das erstmal ein
bisschen so ein widerspruch aber wir
stecken ja auch nicht so wirklich drin
was jetzt genau abgelaufen ist in der
familie groß gewesen
ein blick in die kommentare roya sciacca
ich wäre auch so geworden aber mein
vater ein gürtel
es ist lustig aber es ist auch die weil
genau darum geht es nämlich dass man den
kindern grenzen aufzeigt dass seine
takko ins heim kann man die probleme
immer größer wurden
herzzerreißend weil ich meinen sohn
abgeben musste die leute die mir
wirklich einfach leid das ist es ist
einfach das ist so ein spiel bei dem
keiner was gewinnt versteht ihr was ich
meine leute das ist einfach so einer
situation wo alle darunter leiden wenn
irgendwie das kind warum auch immer sei
es aufgrund erziehung die vielleicht
nicht ganz optimal war sei es aufgrund
übrigen eigenen gehen oder für andere
mimi durchdreht und dass die eltern
nicht damit klar kommen dann werden die
eltern ich glaube ich müsste das kind
abgeben so das kind dreht am rad und die
muss man auch einmal im heimmatch ich
gar nicht was abgeht das ist wirklich
also das ist so die dunkle seite in
diesen sachen so teilweise kann man da
auch ganz gut lachen aber das ist echt
das schon krass weil sie die gefühle
zeigen so verschieden die leute können
ich kann es weniger der es ist wirklich
krass so ich erkenne mich da teilweise
fast ein bisschen gerade drin sondern
gerade bei diesen folgen die strengsten
eltern der welt habe ja schon einmal
gesagt dass ich auch so ein bisschen ein
kleines terror kind war früher und auch
so dieses keinen draht zu den eigenen
emotionen haben das einfach nur
verdrängen so jeder mensch kann mehr
oder weniger guten draht zu den eigenen
emotionen herstellen wenn man die nicht
verdrängt das muss man erst lernen auf
jeden fall das dauert auch eine weile
aber es geht für alle
auch aline sind ihre mitmenschen völlig
egal sie liebt es zu provozieren
anstatt fehlanzeige ja wir sind wieder
los
wer denn jetzt berlin oder sind die
mädels heute noch so aus leute schreibt
dass meine kommentare rhein bei mir
früher an der schule waren die offene
schule also gymnasium realschule
hauptschule als durcheinander möchte ich
war vom gymnasium und der ja das waren
immer die ent gegnerin diese weise
gerückt ist
die waren wirklich gefährlich so die
waren wirklich gefährlich wer guckt denn
da ist ja auch im kopf die guckt sich
little nicht an was guckst du hier komm
ich habe gesehen dass mit dem hinterkopf
bekommen sagt wolle dort nicht geguckt
oder dein leben
was das für das passiert auch in
deutschland das also ich kann mir schon
denken warum aber das passiert nicht so
bedeutend dass ich kenne geisteskrank
alter 16 jahre alt wie mein gott seger
was geht da denn ab alter leute ich kann
euch zu diesem thema auf jeden fall
einen song empfehlen hört euch mal augen
auch von sido an ok da sagt er ungefähr
auch sinngemäß mama macht die augen auf
treibt mir meine flausen aus und ich
glaube das ist genau das was diesen
kindern gefällt was sie nicht bekommen
einfach grenzen und ja und dann gegen
kuwait crazy aber ja leute wenn ihr
vermeiden wollte bis zu 15 anzeigen zu
bekommen dann würde ich vorstellen dass
er ihm ein vorgeschriebenes video
abchecken hier oben ein knall abonniert
ich bin an der stelle raus bleibt stabil
schreibt mir auf meinem ganz in die
kommentare
macht's gut